what up space fam golson here from anime
uproar and today i'm going to
not only give you guys a quick update on
new insane records that demonstrate has
broken
i will also give you my honest thoughts
on the demonstr movie which i
finally got to see so make sure to stay
tuned for that
if you do enjoy seeing demon sayer
videos on this channel and you want to
keep them coming then the best thing you
could do
is smash that like button to let me know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and turn on all notifications or
you will miss
upcoming demon slayer videos and updates
if there are any topics you are burning
up to see
let me know in the comments and while
you wait for me to make that video feel
free
to check out my growing demon slayer
playlist that includes videos on all
breath styles
all demon moons all hashiras and much
more
link to that is in the description now
without further ado
let's jump into it i've been a
demonstrator fan long before it's been
breaking these records
but wow even i a huge fan of the series
never thought it would be this
successful demon slayer mugen train is
the highest grossing anime film of all
time
having grossed a total of about 465
million dollars
at the time of writing this is
significantly ahead of spirited away
which came out in 2001 and held the
record for a very long time
demonstrator has actually significantly
passed spirited away which grossed about
395 million worldwide meaning about
70 million less than demons players so
far
keywords so far because the mugen train
is
still going i've made videos about how
crazy demon slayer's success has been
especially when we consider what's going
on in the world right now and how some
people straight up aren't even willing
to go to the theaters
but i like giving you guys updates on
the numbers since like me
i assume some people find it fascinating
to study and keep up with this instance
of history in the making
keep in mind a while ago demonstrator
already became the top earning movie of
all time
in japan beating out titanic frozen and
harry potter so
everything from here on out is just
bonus you could already say
that demonstrator has made history so
although i had to give you guys that
update first
what i really want to do in this video
is actually get into the movie itself
which i finally got a chance to watch
and to see if it's worthy of its insane
levels of popularity
and in my opinion it definitely is
i can honestly say that i personally
enjoyed the demonstra movie
more than i enjoyed spirited away i
acknowledge that that's subjective but
it's totally true in my case
it's even crazier to think that demon
slayer could beat out spirited away when
it's clearly just a part of a story that
you need background knowledge of the
anime series to fully appreciate
while spirit away and a lot of other top
grossing movies are self-contained
stories
it's a great sign for demon slayer and
for anime series in general
but back to the movie itself it picks up
with tanjiro
zenitsu inosuke and nezuko joining
kyojiro
and goku the flame pillar on the demon
train the animation is
absolutely beautiful after the first
season i was telling
everybody that demon is only going to
get better
having read the manga i already had high
hopes and the movie did not disappoint
and if i haven't given a warning yet
here is my warning that i will get into
movie spoilers
otherwise talking about this movie would
be absolutely no fun for me
if you just want a recommendation then
yes it's great
check it out so into the spoilers we go
i was glad to see that this roughly two
hour long movie
covered both the fight against lower
moon 1 and the fight against
rengoku and upper moon 3 akaza if you
watch my videos
like how strong is rangoku and the best
villain demon slayer
you already know that i think very
highly other than goku
as a character and of akaza as a villain
the anime movie magnified their
greatness
with the beautiful animation the
soundtrack and the voice acting
because they include the fight between
rengoku and akasa the film never felt
like it dragged on for me
and an already good movie kept on
picking up steam
and getting better as it approached its
explosive conclusion
i love the demon slayer characters
they're some of my favorite characters
in all of anime and i really enjoyed
seeing them shine in their own ways in
this movie
because of the unique setup with lower
moon 1
and how he feeds his victims idyllic
dreams
we got to know the characters better and
see what they all value
and what i like is that none of them
value things or money
which are usually foregrounded whether
we're aware of it or not
in capitalistic and consumerist
societies no
in this movie there's a common thing
that they all valued and that was human
connection
they valued their relationships in their
ideal perfect worlds they would be
connecting to people
to their friends or families or
girlfriends in zenith's case
and it makes sense that a movie that
foregrounds human connection
would strike a chord with so many people
during these social distancing times
tanjuro dreamed that his family was
never killed his dream was not to be a
millionaire with a mansion and a harem
rather he dreamed of simply going to
chop up some firewood
while his family waited safely for him
at home he dreamed of spending time with
them
and the fact that they lived a very
simple life with little money
didn't at all interfere with their
happiness similarly
zenitsu dreamed about spending time with
nezuko
about carrying her over a river and i
don't know about you
but i couldn't help but break out in
heartwarming laughter when i
saw how much intense pleasure zenitsu
got from this simple and innocent dream
i also laughed at enosuke's dream where
he
too dreamed of spending time with his
newfound friends
except his position as leader was more
clear than it is in real life
and our main characters also took on
animal-like attributes
then goku for his part simply dreamed
about spending time with his little
brother
he was teaching him the proper way to
swing a sword and supporting him along
the way
like i said although they all had
different twists like inosuke's
hilarious twist
they all fundamentally dreamed of being
with their close ones
and i think that's significant it puts
into perspective what's important in
life
where we get the most joy from it
reminds us that we can live simply
and yet happily as long as we're
surrounded by the right people
and especially in tanjiro's case since
his family is no longer around
his story reminds us how important is to
value our own families
and friends too while they're still
around because you never know
what tomorrow will bring senitsu saving
nezuko was amazing that and goku
protecting
five train carts at once without getting
tired was amazing
any nosuke and tanjiro tag teaming lower
moon 1
was you guessed it amazing having
tanjuro take his own life in the dream
every time in order to wake up was so
powerful
especially when he was almost tricked
into doing in real life
and inosuke had to stop him this had to
be a team effort
tundra would have been dead if not for
inosuke's help and i loved their
bromance too
tundra wanted to save the guy that
stabbed him while inosuke wanted to kill
him because he hurt his good friend
and i loved seeing how hinosuke insisted
that he was the leader
and when tundra told him to do something
he rationalized it by saying that of
course
he would fulfill his subordinates
request it's the least he could do as
the leader after all
although i'd say zenitsu is my favorite
of the three overall in the series
i love them all and inosuke was probably
my favorite
specifically in this film all of this
greatness happened and just as it seemed
that things were winding down
an upper moon shows up out of nowhere
and that's when rengoku steals the
spotlight and shines like no
other if there's ever been a right time
to say someone went out in a blaze of
glory
it's ran goku in this film i love the
philosophy of demon slayer and i talked
about it a lot
in my the controversial philosophy of
demon slayer video
we see clashing philosophies at play
during the battle between akazan and
goku akasa is very practical and demons
are better because they can live forever
they instantly heal for moons and their
powers get amplified
so why wouldn't people want to become
demons akaza unlike lower moon 1
seems like kind of a nice dude at least
towards people who are strong enough to
earn his respect
he really doesn't want to kill rengoku
he wants rengoku to become
a demon so they can continue to fight
forever he insists
that a human can't beat a demon soren
goku should just become one
and akaza makes a good argument rengoku
would have won many times over if akaza
was human
but he just healed time after time while
akaza got a few deadly hits on rengoku
and it sealed his fate
yet even when he knew he was going to
die then goku refused to become a demon
rengoku valued human life precisely
because
it was fragile and temporary those
qualities made it all
the more beautiful and after all as
tanjira said
you can make the argument that and goku
did manage to win as a human
yes rengoku died and akaza lived but
akaza is the one that ran away before
the battle was concluded through a lens
of honor
then goku kept his honor to the end
bravely fighting for his principles
while akaza dishonored himself by
running in fear from the sun
then goku's goal was to save everyone
and he succeeded in saving everyone
else at the cost of his own life tanjuro
brings up a great point when he calls
the demons cowards
the demon slayers always fight during
the night where the demons have the
advantage
and yet as soon as the sun starts coming
out
they run away then goku may have died
but his fiery will
the example of his blazing heart was
passed on to those he saved while akasa
cowered and ran away in fear from the
sun
then goku welcomed his death with a
smile on his face
his principles had led him to his death
but more importantly they led him to
peace and fulfillment
i was touched and i wouldn't be
surprised if everyone got teary eyed or
straight up bawled their eyes out when
and goku passed
away inosuke's reaction hit me
especially hard
because of how he was telling the others
not to cry while his own tears were
making their way through his boar mask
his words of how even if you feel
miserable pathetic and embarrassed
sometimes
you just gotta keep on living touched me
and i think we all need to hear that at
some point in our lives
there are going to be tragedies like
rengoku's death
like losing family members friends or
people we care about
but we keep going we keep going for them
as well as for ourselves
until it's our turn to go i'm not going
to get into spoilers beyond the movie
in case you haven't read the rest of the
manga but i will say that this movie
will be
all the more powerful once you finish
the entire story which is yet another
reason that i love it
so yeah long story short i thought this
movie was
amazing not just because i love the
story and the animation
but also because i loved its philosophy
it foregrounds the importance of
relationships
and living and dying by your principles
compared to romanticizing money
things dreams or even immortality it
brings our attention to the fleeting and
beautiful nature of life and in doing so
it can help us step back from our
day-to-day autopilot
existence it can help us gain
perspective on our lives
and on what's truly important and if you
ask me
that's exactly what great art is
supposed to do
and that is it for this one thank you so
much for watching if you did enjoy this
video and want to keep the demon slayer
videos coming
be sure to smash that like button to let
me know if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell and turn on
all notifications or you will miss
upcoming demonstrator videos if there
are any specific topics you are
burning up to see let me know in the
comments long lived and goku
rest in peace you beautiful flame pillar
and while we wait for the next demon
slayer season to come out
feel free to check out my growing demon
slayer playlist that includes videos on
all breath styles all demon moons all
hashiras and much more
link to that is in the description and i
especially want to thank the patron
squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
patrons of legend the ones
acknowledged by lord twigo himself alpha
sigma red haired raven and
av and our one tier patrons the ones who
stand atop
all clans ingrata pate heffa al-jatal
dr cortman the toasted chi bang emperor
taku spy life tinel
tungsten tarkis baked buddhist and yuno
and our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only gilgamesh steelers angel cruz
anatoly kazatsky cricket xp return day
aura
very gucci alicia actor bonnie park
sino-kami and water joanne garcia ted
note 10
isparky65 jessica lafond metal mama
corey mcgowan fat boy games deadly
saints soul rye slice and dice and pill
you
thank you all so much if you enjoy our
work you can support more of it by going
over to patreon.com
animeopro and becoming a patreon today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these
amazing people right here and you'll
even get access to our private patron
only discord where we talk about anime
life and of course thank memes so check
out patreon.com
anime upload link in the description if
you're interested you can also join the
youtube channel by clicking that blue
join button next to subscribe button
that you've hopefully
already destroyed so yeah you can
support more content that way if you
prefer
and whichever way to support us you will
get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you